Um, if Trump were to call you and say,
"Hey, I want you to be my specialist on
this." What do you what would be your
plan on policy dealing with what who
would you even mark off as our kind of
the Muslim lead places in the in the
East? Well, I mean, Dearborn, Michigan.
Yeah. I mean, Dearborn is a problem. We
got to start domestically, you know,
obviously. And um you know no way room
shape or form for any kind of Sharia
introductions cuz these laws I mean
they're in they're in the UK you know
and and they they they play around with
the laws they introduce it but all it is
is allowing you know Sharia stipulations
to kind of creep in between contracts is
what what I see in Dearborn. Right.
Yeah. And then judges are honoring that
since you made your contract I have to
honor your Sharia. So that would have to
go and um you know migration from known
radical nations. I mean one of the worst
to be honest with you is like Somalia.
Yes. Minneapolis. Look at Minneapolis.
And I look at Minneapolis and it's kind
of like you know and it's not and then
they treat that as racism. It's not
racism. You know he did that a while
back. Trump the first the first term
remember he they called it the Muslim
ban, right? It was like seven nations.
It was seven it and some of them weren't
even Muslim but it was the seven nations
that were like known for terrorism.
Okay. It's a it's a smart simple
solution. You know, it's it's like what
we were talking about with Hungary and
Poland. Um so, you know, that sort of
thing. But the truth is in America,
Islam is not as much of a problem as in
Europe because Muslims are like I think
something like 1% or you know, 2%. And
that's why they um you know, they can be
curtailed. Uh you know, the issue is
here's the thing you know about Islam
you have to understand and and is is in
Islam it's like it's a political
ideology. I mean, Islam is not, you
know, the Christian idea or separation
of church and state, whatever that
means, but it's very much in the now.
It's not something I do in my heart with
God or some belief. It's very much, I
mean, Sharia law is everything about the
now. And you know, one thing is Muslims
are obligated to be loyal to Islam and
not loyal. The Quran tells them they
have to hate non-Muslims and they cannot
be loyal to them. Can you imagine that's
what it says? And to me that's like how
do you come to America and take the
pledge and you know pledge you know
loyalty to a nation that's of run by
infidels when your own book is telling
you you can never do that right so I
mean I personally I would like to see
these questions at least brought up and
openly debated with Muslims instead but
of course they would never do that in
this you know climate because freedom of
religion. Um so but maybe we're creeping
up on that. I mean, it seems like what
we're seeing in the UK and in Europe,
though, is starting to get people like,
"Wait, wait, wait, wait. What's going
on?" And and the kind of corruption
that's being uncovered in the in in
police and law enforcement where they're
looking the other way. Um, you know,
allowing these crimes to be committed in
the name of multiculturalism. This is
just their culture. They beat their
wives. They rape, you know, they rape
yours. Yeah. What like I mean, I think I
mean, kind of like the the the
thing has kind of really backfired. I
mean, in the last couple of years in the
States especially. I mean, you had all
this momentum and there's these
hospitals doing all these awful
surgeries and all of a sudden people are
like, "Wait, wait, wait, wait. You're
doing what?" to to 12-year-old girls?
You're doing what to little boys and and
you know, you're you're disfiguring them
for the rest of their life. You're
giving them the these hormone blockers,
all the rest of And a whole bunch of
like like not particularly pious people,
just like kind of red-blooded American
types were like, "No, no, like like you
can't do that." And I wonder if
something similar is about to happen
where it's like, okay, your your holy
book says some stuff that it's like you
you have you you got to pick like you
can't you can't come you can't be doing
this because you're plant like you're
this is inherently political. It's
inherently cultural. It's inherently
antagonistic to our way of life to to
Christian way of life. I I wonder if
we're creeping up on a line where people
actually say wait you want to do what?
Yeah. Yeah. Well, the thing about Islam
is it actually has a game plan that is
like that based on Muhammad's own life,
right? If you look at the Quran, it's
actually divided in in phases. And this
is how it's the the exites understand
it, which is basically Muhammad's
earliest career, he preached peace cuz
he was weak and outnumbered, right? Then
he went to Medina and he became
basically a warlord, right? And there
was a transitional phase where, you
know, he said, "Okay, you can fight back
now." And then there's the final phase
where he says, "Now you can go on the
offensive." Right? And and I'll give you
a funny so basically I'll give you a
funny anecdote from when I was at the
Library of Congress and he was my he was
a f he was my friend because we worked
in the same place and we would you know
speak Arabic because that's what they
speak and but he was a serious Muslim
you know and um I would always pick his
brain and so you know I would ask him
about the violent verses they're known
as the Mecca the Mecca verses are the
peaceful and the Medina verses are the
violent ones. Okay. So I would be like,
"Well, what about, you know, the violent
versus this and that?" And and he
finally got frustrated and he's like,
"Well, I'm living in Mecca right now."
So I'm in the phase of being peaceful
because I'm weak and outnumbered, right?
No, that's I think that's facts. That's
that's crazy. Yeah. Ask Ask the
homosexuals. They're figuring out that
in some cities, right? What happens?
We're in the We're in the right. So
then, you know, what is it? Um I guess I
don't know where which one to ask first.
I have two questions. I kind of want to
know what do you think makes the West
strong and then what what do what does
Islam think makes the West strong? What
do you think our strength is? Why do
they want the West? Well, I know why
they want it. I think what made the West
strong is Christianity and Christendom
and that whole in that, you know, that
energy. And I think the reason the West
is still strong is because it was such a
strong heritage that we're kind of
living off borrowed time and borrowed
resources from that being squandered
left and right, of course. Right. Um, as
far as what the, you know, Islam thinks,
Islam just thinks we have good
technology. And so for the longest time,
they would say learn their technology,
learn their, you know, the scientific
ways, but do not deal with their culture
or their religion because that's all
poison. Okay. So they would just they
would think we're advanced
technologically. So they just think it's
our technology. So if they learn that,
they think they can Yeah. Yeah. They
want to they want to take our knowledge,
right, and then re employ it. Yeah. And
I would say that's actually more a lot
of cultures, not just Islam. They they
really look down on Western culture. I
mean, but because of this woke trans
stuff, you know, it's it's so despicable
to normal people. Right. Right. I mean,
as despicable it is to us, to people
outside of the West, it's just like
what? Yes. You people are having
problems figuring out using pronouns,
right? Like we're really kind of we're
kind of stupid, you know? It's
embarrassing. Yeah. Like like I I just I
have to say, you know, it's and this is
how bad it is. They have us so, you
know, brought down, our standards are so
brought down low that we need our
president to intervene and, you know,
get rid of pronoun stuff and we and to
us that's a victory. We're happy. Like,
what a waste, you know? Shouldn't we be
doing something else with our time and
energy, right? So for for mo for most of
the non-western world when they look at
that and I see and I read and I watch it
I mean to them it's a joke